hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing
reckoning at gun manners so we're in a
bit of a pickle because we got to find
this McCready person for the person in
the parlor we've made the chili but we
need to kill it before we can give it to
the person who eats ghost food and
there's seven other no there's five
other ghosts somewhere it's two on the
first floor three on the second two on
the third who's the one on the third
I'll talk to you later okay I'm on the
second floor right now on the first
floor right now so who are the ghosts
here we got lard oh the pants guy okay
so we got to find some pants list pants
and then we got to deal with the guy in
the dining room that's the two up there
the three on the second floor are
technically the librarians what does the
librarian even need what do you need I
was wondering how you died I was caught
in the crossfire in a library shootout
wow what happened
a pair of ruffians got into a heated
argument over the comparative merits of
anton chekhov versus henrik ibsen when
who started shooting I attempted to step
in and stop them I simply won't abide
gunfire in the library is far too loud
that was your only objection the noise
that was quite sufficient I won't
tolerate by the way my cheeks are still
in pain and they're still recovering but
the swelling has gone down I won't
tolerate noise of any stripe and
certainly not gunfire I was in versus
check off huh what was the point of
their contention I don't recall that
particular is I just remember Chekhov
fans shouting remember that gun I showed
you in act 1 before opening fire
the noise was dreadful Oh I'll see what
I can do I'll see what I can do I didn't
even have an opportunity to see what I
could do I don't know what I needed to
do what are you talking about there's no
noise in here there's no gunfire what
hey I know how to make guns quiet Oh huh
how many times do I have to tell you
sorry but I know how to make guns quiet
oh really can you show me you not and
quickly and quietly leave the library
gather materials for a silent or head to
the lab to craft it oh that's because I
already attached to my gun that is
incredibly helpful I invented this thing
that makes guns really quiet
Oh marvelous finally I can rest in peace
knowing that libraries will now be safe
from the noise of gunfire it is only in
an atmosphere of quiet that true joy
dare live Bertrand Russell and with that
she dissipates into nothingness he isn't
he isn't famous yet ok then well that's
another one
down so that leaves two on the second
floor who's the other one on the second
floor not in the restroom in one of the
guest rooms so is this dude over here
number four what do you need what are
the novelties oh I need to figure out
how to make a cigar explode so maybe
there's something I could do in the lab
down below with the cigar that I have to
make it explode that's the only thing
that I could possibly think of because
the only other thing here I guess I
haven't been back to the place down here
very much it's gotta be something right
examine it we got this Islander got the
gun so there's nothing here that can
help us make tin exploding what Yuma
call it mmm this can't be anything else
down here okay let me wander around a
bit I'm gonna try to find why are you
here no are you here well my phone oh
these plants have such flatness in
rectangle yeah hedges they're grown in
that way in a fancy garden sometimes it
is craziness a nature perversion all the
stuff we've seen and done this is what
you get mad about let me walk around for
a bit and I'm gonna try to find just
nothing where is this place
I'm gonna try to find what we need to do
next wait I just had an idea there is a
cemetery somewhere yeah petting
cemeteries reboot Hill military cemetery
there's a couple cemeteries do I need to
go find McCready's grave the Dave yard
oh no that's the that's the graveyard
with only Dave's in it I forgot about
that
I'll give him a ride to dirt water all
right you got two horses why don't you
ride them you know how to rise because a
cart horses Oh oops
oh god damn it oh well huh all right
comb his mane give him some peanut
butter he makes a sort of Clerk nice
peanut butter makes Tim Fleur flap his
lips and open its closed my forgot about
Tim plur hung a clip drape shipshape
tip-top sock that's weird it looks like
you're actually talking somebody wants
to pay this curtain our tubs Oh mmm the
orange peanut for me Wow well I accept
you Oh
let's go Templar all right I'm going to
find okay you know what maybe it
wouldn't be
some doesn't seem right about this I
don't know 100% about this McCready have
I seen the name McCready anywhere you
know one name McCready I guess you know
whatever let's go back to dirt water
does anybody in town heard of McCready
hey bartender you ever heard of McCready
oh I didn't know about that I swear what
ever hear about a fella named McCready
McCready nope don't ring a bell it would
have been about 17 years ago heck I got
a long memory but not that long I only
started working here about six or seven
years ago anyway what about the guest
register we only keep those look for the
last couple of years only place I know
of might have been the records as far
back see we need would be the post
office okay it's incredibly handy hello
I'm trying to find a guy named Akriti
there's a possibility he might have
passed through here about 17 years ago
passed through we don't stand passports
here if he stayed for a while I might
have a forwarding address who can you
check please all right then books could
use a dust in anyway one sick she pulls
out a big Ledger's of her out of her
desk and blows it huge cloud to dust in
the air and then starts leaving through
him 17 years round about 78 then 76 Oni
1877 Marin Mabel sin McMurphy McCready
got a Matt McCready not the one that's
him no forwarding address but you could
ask at his old place just out the
northwest of here let me see your map
yeah it looks like he already got it
here desert house that's the one really
I really this this place here is McCrea
this always them that's where the gang
was holed up wait yikes
wait and maccreedy stuck to his guns dig
up the grave oh you dig up the wooden
coffin haul the lid open a skeleton
blinks at you or well it doesn't but
anyway howdy howdy are you guilty
McCready well now I ain't heard that
nickname in what year is it 1895 17
years now I tell lie there was that one
time he'd years ago the same McCready
that escaped the gallows during an
eclipse well now since the statute of
limitations is expired I might as well
fess up yeah that was me Reese we'd
planned to apart from the one little
hitch it went off smooth as silk
even worked in a little
mr. correction to lead the law to their
mother to fell instead of me here serves
him right - there was real murderers not
like me I never killed a man cept in a
fair fight except for that one little
hitch you mentioned you miscalculated
how long to delay the trial so in order
not to miss the Eclipse you called for a
trial by combat
oh well yep that's the truth of it
you're blaming me for Miss Wainwright's
death I suppose why didn't you just
trust her she would have gotten you
declared innocent she had a real good
head on her shoulders sure but so did
that prosecutor fella
I didn't rate the odds better than 5050
not good enough and anyway the trial by
combat was part of a job she should have
been ready that stinks she trusted you
she's a ghost now because she feels
guilty about losing that trial
I've spent ages trying to convince her
you weren't innocent and she backed you
every step of the way despite the fact
that you got her killed
and you don't even care hell you bite
your tongue Sonny you don't know me
don't care I did what I felt I had to do
to stay alive and I felt damn guilty
about what happened to miss Wainwright
but I'm taking all the blame for it no
sir
she'll tell you herself she should have
been better prepared just like she told
me that day apologize into her last
breath I gave up gun fighting for her I
gave up the only thing I live for that's
about how I feel about it
you gave up gun fighting one easy but I
did bought this house bought this land
raised some chickens and had a little
vegetable garden place is going to hell
since I died that's a shame anyway I
never fired my pistol again not even at
the damn fence post that's not what it
says on your grave oh yeah
read it again that's the fella what
cubed me having a little ironic joke I
reckon somebody killed you you're only a
second person to track me down first one
was nine years after the trial victims
burries brother hunting for revenge what
happened he challenged me to a duel and
I told him I ain't doing that no more he
asks again and I said no and he hollered
at me and I took my pistol out of the
closet and threw it at his feet so she
could see how the cylinders was all
rusted shut and he cocked his gun and
asked me one last time and I said no and
last thing I remember was the bang geez
count a.m. to bury me though guess he
weren't all that bad do you want to see
Felicity again I could take her to you
as a go
now I reckon I'll just go back to sleep
ain't right a dead fella walking around
to sell us sorry for me all right
here you can give it my pocket Walsh she
recognize it
Lucretius pocket watch fancy silver
pocket watch meet gates whoa
meet Kingston I don't hello it's pretty
good I'm too powerful as it is I might
do that all right bye McCready so long
fella so long well that was that was
quite nice quite that's quite something
as all right so I've got the gun manner
which gives a lot of moxie and damage I
guess I don't really need the meat and I
don't need the items habit you know it
it's fine I'll take the damage I'd
rather just trounce on some some Normie
ghosts in the in the basement or
whatever I'd rather just be have the
ability to do that but no wait is not
the right one oh I forget that there's
two doors and the one closer isn't the
right door what a stupid mansion okay
second floor hey lady you're finally
done my god just get over it are you
ready for this what now I found
McCready's grave he wasn't executed
you're you're a 100% certain it's him
not some other man named McCready it was
him here he gave me his watch to give to
you she turns to watch round in her
hands for a while just looking at it
without saying anything then she slowly
wins it and listens as it chimes the
hour yeah this is his watch all right
thank you wait you said he gave it to
you he's alive well not exactly he's a
skeleton we talked for a while and then
he asked me to bury him again so he
could go back to sleep
What did he say well he confirmed our
guesses he knew about the Eclipse in
advance installed the trial for his
escape plan
but stalled it too long and decided to
hedge his bed by calling for the trial
by combat I see he gave up gun fighting
he what he bought a little house and
raised chickens never five his pistol
again
in fact he left it to rust nine years
later Tim's buries brother caught up to
him and challenged him to a revenge
match but Creedy refused repeatedly so
the guy shot him he said to tell you he
was sorry she looks at you silently for
a moment then looks at the watch she
wins the hand back a minute and listens
as it chimes again she sighs and shakes
her head then smiles at you thank you
mum Fleur he'd make a damn fine attorney
she shakes your hand
from view as she does so leaving her
attorneys badge in your hand oh whoa
whoa whoa damn you did the best items in
the game in this TLC and what are you
gonna use it on nothing
rest in peace that was pretty good I
like that story arc those those really
good Hey
my medal of adequacy I'm not sure which
one's better I think I'm gonna stick
with my medal of adequacy if it's all
right I like like the idea I just really
like you hey my spleen my spleen still
got capacity I've got some XP here so I
should probably do better on well
shootin an EI fan the hammer baby fan
ham maybe that sounds like a good wound
quick on the draw dirty poker sure
hardly knew her
yeah and Moxie okay got me upgrades
nothing I might need them being more
powerful at this juncture doesn't
exactly do me any good that's another
that's another ghost come on that means
we only got how many five left one on
this floor who's the other one I took
care of the library and oddly enough
who's the other one on this floor uh-oh
the guest that's right I need to find a
way to make an exploding pickle let's go
up to the third floor cuz I got to
remember exactly what I need to do here
the pool guy you what did I need to do
for you oh I need ghost chalk where in
the hell am I gonna get ghost chalk how
would I do that
only you would understand where I would
start it says there are two ghosts up
here two ghosts on the third but the
only other one that I know of is in the
billiards room does that mean the missus
gun is a ghost cuz if there's two ghosts
up here and the only one is the
billiards ghost then that means if it
means what I think it means it means
that there's something going on and let
me fight some ghosts I want to see I
want to see if this actually could do
something what have a fan the hammer oh
my gosh shoot the target four times
doing 500 damage oh my god let me see I
want to see if I can get enough bowling
ball chunks to like maybe combine them
into something
on ball hat oh let me see if there's
some stuff to be had here I don't know
if there is oh oh my oh my god oh my god
oh oh my oh my god oh my god
oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] that hurts so bad and
why can't none of my other guys hit
anything a fan hammer on you and I'm
gonna risk it
she sums okay ow and I'm angry good
thing I didn't get any more angry
because I would have fallen over and
died and then I would have lost all my
buffs for the day and then I would have
passed out and it would have been no
good alright cheap cigar I've already
got plenty of cheap cigars so what do I
do with the cheap cigars I got to make
it into a bomb how do I make it into a
bomb I don't understand anything all
right how would we kill this chili that
we've got cuz we've got a bowl of chili
how do we kill it how do you kill chili
oh there's a pair of your size fancy
pantry pants oh alright well that's
handy cold resistance pants just in case
you need them there all right so we're
am I gonna get more pants I've been
everywhere in this manner I can't think
of a single place that I haven't been
and there's nothing in the basement
that's gonna be additional what about
this place wait what is that
that's a wheel on a cart I thought there
was something else yeah what about this
place rats it I don't know what that
means
oh my god it's a Sophia with some nice
throw pillows smother the chilly
with a pillow oh my god you sigh and do
it has to be done Chili's in pistol is
muerto oh my god oh oh okay that makes
perfect sense
I'm that's fine this is good this is
what you call good yeah that's great hey
buddy you hand the ghost the ghostly
bowl of chili and immediately gobbles it
up with a long's finally satisfied sigh
he dissipates Happy Trails big guy hey
buddy thank you so much for dealing with
that ghost I am exhausted what were you
even doing he kept them
and ghost food but I don't really know
how to cook except like nachos and
popcorn and just the regular kind not
ghost nachos and popcorn but he really
was insistent so I figured ghost food is
probably invisible right so I just
pretended and gave him empty plates
here's a work even though that doesn't
really make sense anyway thanks again I
work at the snack bar in the visitors
center so I'll see you there alright
well I guess I'll go over there see
what's going on in the snack bar and
maybe he can help me progress him one of
the other story lines I'm getting close
there's only three wink wink wink wink
wonk wonk there's only three only three
ghosts wink wink wink wonk left snack
catters now there you see what's for
sale well how do I have to buy a
gun-shaped cookie I would have done
today
cookie give my spell damage um is there
anything in this that I actually need
because I don't think so I'm pretty sure
the answer would be no right right
where's the photo guy yeah where's the
photo guy I don't remember seeing any
other people in the manner so I don't
know where they would be okay so the
only thing left to do at this juncture
because I am missing some chalk for the
thing and that's about it I just need to
go to every single room again check
everything because at this point I'm
lost and I'm not a hundred percent sure
where to go and typically this could
this games been good about guiding you
to the right place but man I am just I'm
lost I need some ghost chalk I need to
find a way to make a pickle explode and
I need pants so it doesn't seem like it
would be that bad but I seem to be at
loss
Blake chalkboard Oh God
boo but chalk take the chalk yes that
that should be enough I have chalk there
was a chalkboard it booed me but it was
a chalkboard I think that's gonna be it
okay so that's gonna be usually usually
what I'm finding is usually the solution
is on the same floor wink wink wink monk
so
yeah let's do this okay it's a close
match you have to consult the geometry
book a few times to his work out the
angles
the game comes down to fight for the
eight ball and you managed to barely
squeak out the wind when the ghost
catches an unlucky bounce off the corner
of the pocket well shucks nice shootin
Tex he flips you a finger gun salute
winks and fades into nothingness now I
just need to find pantaloons and if I'm
going by the same logic I had before
it's gotta be right here rats sit sit
rat ratty sit sit my rat yeah maybe it's
not as far as let me talk to this man
again hey how you doing hey I'm serious
sick of your weird area here and also
your weird face no yeah but I'll keep
looking okay so it's not in here that
much is clear three ghosts left current
location blues that lower half off I
could just blows upper half off to match
and we could call it a day but would you
would you blow it off of see not so
simple
you dumb you stupid I've been turning
the lamps off I don't know why I feel
like it actually does something but it
probably does not lard-ass does not help
me the cold pantry does not help me
nothing here helps me yeah he's gotta be
some pants some pantless pants oh wait
this guy wait yeah Paul Paul I took care
of the ghost I forgot about Paul oh [ __ ]
all right okay thank you ahem oh thank
god I've got to wash this flower off and
get back to work but first he starts
frantically scratching every part of his
body man feels like I've been saving up
these stitches for days I was about to
go crazy thanks mom flu you're a
lifesaver
no problemo comes to me at the Visitor
Center I'll hook you up with a souvenir
photograph he might have gunpowder for
the flash oh [ __ ] wait a minute that's a
good point
let me just let me just make sure that
whatever lamp is in here is off it is
off is there another one in the back I
don't know what it would do if I did but
I kind of wanted to try to turn off all
the lamps why not gonna do much of
anything but you know I am a pointless
[ __ ] so I do what I can
all right so you have got
powder correct please say yes thanks
again for your help what an ordeal no
problem how's the itching I'm more or
less better I mean hygiene is what it is
in this day and age you know you nod
would you like a souvenir photograph
it's only 200 meet already to sell
something do this Candyman alright
bowling ball chunks those can go all
those these new fancy pantry pants can
go tin caviar crease your meat drop
bonus buy 25 for the rest of the day I'm
okay I don't need it so I'm just gonna
throw it away uh now I'm gonna do it
sure I'll take one
okay then smile wait a second this is a
photograph of the house yep an official
gun man or souvenir photo all right why
did you take a picture of me then oh
just for our records
I'd go okay but sorry only one photo per
customer I'm not sure why anybody would
want to buy two but fair enough but yo I
thought I thought for certain like the
flash would have like gunpowder you know
what I mean like for exploding cigar
really I'm so smart I'm big smart these
guys aren't appreciating my big smart
brain alright there's got to be like
some kind of a secret here Oh what the
hell how did how have I not been here
that must be the hedge wizard give him a
trimming oh okay
hedges heed my call right man you suck
can I do a shoot a nanny will it just
spill over to the other guy there we go
a little [ __ ]
alright you've only succeeded in kicking
the hedge wizard ass down the road aways
it was still pretty satisfying alright
let's chase that jerk down oh it's a big
topiary w maybe it stands for why would
somebody make a topiary W that's a good
point well at least you didn't run very
far not far enough by far hedges heed my
call okay I'm still just gonna shoot a
nanny you say I mean a fan the hammer
you oh [ __ ] you're still here spores
well [ __ ] or can I just shoot you
bang easy find him and end it okay he
ran away again
H is for heads probably oh my god what
is that okay at this point he's got
nowhere left to run to well assuming
that weird portal behind him is exit
only alright hedges heed my call
alright let's blast all the enemies well
that was much better than whatever crap
you were doing before
maybe dynamite yeah dynamite the other
guy's row row row just in case I don't I
don't think I need to put you know just
in case I've got him and I might as well
use them I don't want him risk cuz I got
I got wham too by the freaking bowling
ball so I might as well just blast these
guys got ya
finally you got an item the hedge
Wizards Journal somebody has scrawled
private do not read HW on in spite of
his journal
ohw it's his initials the hedge Wizards
orb this is the orb a mystical leaves
from whence the hedge wizard arrived all
of his powers unless it was one of those
the magic was inside you all along
scenarios maybe you never know what is
this hedge wizard secret stash in a
treasure chest of goblin manufacturer
you got 742 meeting and hedging your
bets this is the book the hedge wizard
used to earn enough meat to become a
wizard the terminology is just a
coincidence oh that's funny
read you read the book and learn all
about the things a financial
responsibility and decorative
horticulture have in common
Oh 20% of meat games after reading the
book you resolved to make some budget
cuts but you mistake the book for your
budget and cut it into pieces instead
that's dumb that's dumb i'ma read this
journal is full of terrible poetry
here's an example everlasting shrubbery
nobly leaf crowd away handle me rigged
the atmosphere up in here everlasting
shrubbery and cut the music
everlasting shrubbery put in some
different music never
robbery nobly leaf crowned whence comes
all joy sweeps like fragrance wondrous
died strength namaste namaste Bible that
is terrible let's read it again
oh no it's the same thing oh I thought
it was a randomly generated one out Kay
whatever alright it's some kind of
portal back kick in the music again it's
some kind of portal native and filled
with enchanted shrubbery right so what
was the point of this what I didn't even
know this was here is there more stuff
in this maze I guess it is a maze it's
got a little nooks and crannies but did
I do any good oh oh oh oh oh [ __ ] oh
it's the actual maze wait okay so there
is they're actually like a way out of
this okay anywhere in this did I find a
code of some kind anywhere like a
pattern or anything like that that would
help me get out of that because that
actually is interesting maybe maybe the
poem east northeast north west south
north yes east north west south west
north got it I've got it I've got it
everybody east north west south west
north the hedge Wizards orb starts
vibrating as you get close to this weird
human shaped bush
touch it not you again wait you're not
him sure no bomb mum Fleur nice to meet
you
I'm the hedge the hedge yeah the hedge
the source of all magic in the maze yada
yada boy I can't tell you how glad I am
to see somebody besides that dorky
wizard did did you
yep I took care of him thank you I made
the mistake of granting him a boon and
he started treating me like a god or
something coming around day after day
prostrating himself before me like a
huge dweeb
just awful I mean sure I'm powerful and
all that but it's not like I did
anything to get this way I mean I'm
rooted into the ground for heaven's
sakes I just grew this way anyway you
mentioned oh sure sure I guess I owe you
that much forget
another clown here you go heads bends
towards you and touches you with one of
his bows I've been blessed by the hedge
oh cool no imagining now I'm I should be
getting back to my business here you can
see yourself out right you should leave
him alone you wouldn't want him to think
you're some kind of a dweeb I might I
might want that I might I might I might
want that hey hey buddy hey listen pal
listen all right whatever I guess I'm a
dweeb well I thought that was gonna help
me progress the storyline I still don't
know how to make a cigar explode or
nothing I am just make something Oh Oh
aha
a wreath of laurels regenerating nine HP
for comet that's nice a weapon
Bushwhacker getting hit with this okay
how about a salad ha ha magic infused
salad I have no more leaves
I guess I'm leaving oh there's a plaid
skirt in here that's sort of like
legless pants oh is that gonna work
you could definitely convince a guy in
the pantry that this is a kilt ah but do
I have to kill them first I don't know
if I have to smother them with a pillow
to make them ghost pants or ghost skirt
that might work and then all that would
leave would be the cigar one and then
mrs. gun was probably a ghost how about
this skirt look I understand the
generation of clothing maybe shouldn't
be a thing but I'm kind of old-fashioned
did I say skirt
I meant kilt what's a kilt it's a
special kind of foreign legless pants
for men here try it
the ghost tries on the skirt I mean
killed hey that's really nice thanks
Ally with his pants problem solved he
dissipates into the ether that is great
then all I need to do is make a cigar
explode without being overly deadly and
then that's it right right right
bling blong bling wonk wonk wonk right
you know the [ __ ]
wait a second what if you stuck this
into the one that so I had the thing the
whole time I completely forgot I got
this from that toy mine outside of the
kids room so long ago yeah what if wait
a second if you stuck this in one of
those I knew is that right outside the
door of where I need no it's in a
different location it's in the children
but that's that's the same general
principle I got an exploding cigar
hilarious Oh God damn it I had it with
me the entire time Frick my dick okay
anyway it's fine hey buddy look you're
about to be hilarious hey friend did you
figure out yeah here I think this is
what you're looking for that's an
exploding cigar yep
sometimes the cigar is just a cigar but
not this time what do you use for the
explosive I found a really small
firecracker just big enough to blow up
the cigar without it also blowing up
someone's face also without that you
know violent lead projectile you're a
genius
please let me see it in action before I
can finally rest light it up
oh boy kaboom
oh he vibrated into nothingness all
right
what's up Docs she raisin an eyebrow at
you and glances at one of her there's
only one let ghost left in the manner
and the premises and it's on the third
floor so this must be mrs. gun that's
the only explanation for this right it
must be mrs. gun knock I do feel
significantly less haunted just get rid
of all the ghosts we sure did ma'am
actually my scanner says there's still
one Shh ma'am all ghosts accounted for
well that splendid come right in oh I
knew it I knew it uh uh hello mrs. gun
hello mum Fleur was it thank you so much
for getting rid of all that goes for me
yeah about that turns out there's one
left oh dear well I'll need you to take
care of it before I can pay you this gun
I've got some bad news for you oh what's
that it's you you're a ghost ma'am well
I'll be when did that happen I wonder my
condolences why thank you you're very
kind
you know this does explain some things
like
what well I haven't had any appetite for
months nearly a year in fact they kept
sending food up from the kitchen in the
dumbwaiter
but I've just been dropping it out the
window and sending the empty plates back
so the chef won't have her feelings hurt
there's also the fact that you're well
translucent yeah I thought it was just
the cataracs mrs. Gunn this prompts a
question you know oh well what's that
why are you a ghost
well I'm sure I don't know you're the
expert perhaps you can tell me
mm actually that's me I am the expert do
you have some kind of unfinished
business something that's tying you to
this place well now that you mention it
yes I suppose I do do you mind telling
me about it
my entire family disappeared a few years
ago my husband my three daughters oh
yeah I heard about that I'm sorry for
your loss
the sheriff suspected they'd been
kidnapped for ransom but no one ever
made any demands they just vanished I
never found out what happened I always
thought they were taken away by ghosts
what did you think that I've always felt
guilty about how many people have been
killed by my adventure the belt buckle
the gun oh right yeah I used to worry
that their ghosts would come back to
haunt me when I built this house I had
an electrical anti ghost field installed
in the walls of this room so they
couldn't get in no way awesome wait
doesn't that affect you well I'm sure it
would if I attempted to walk through the
wall but it never occurred to me to try
after dan and the girls disappeared I
became so sure that ghosts gotten them
that I locked myself in here after
donating the rest of the house of the
Historical Society so that there'd be
someone to look after the place now I
feel rather silly about the whole thing
silly I mean ghosts do exist obviously
well yes but now that I'm a ghost myself
I can sense the presence of other ghosts
and they only just arrived in this house
yesterday or the day before that's when
I called for the exterminator you know I
didn't even question how I knew where
they were there but I don't think there
have been any ghosts here before then
huh why don't they all show up yesterday
I couldn't say they all seemed very
angry and confused but since they
couldn't get in here they gave up and
started just wandering around the house
they gave up quite easily actually
maybe because you were already ghosts
yourself well MS Gunn what are we gonna
do with you
would he mean you did contact me for 13
ghost men you're the 13th oh yes
obviously I could simply renegotiate the
number with you but perhaps you should
go ahead and exorcise me or whatever you
do I'd rather find a more peaceful
solution
a peaceful solution well what do you
mean well we can also release you from
your ghosts titude by solving the
problem that's keeping you here
in your case I guess that means finding
out what happened to your family well
well
aha would be grateful if you could I
assume they're dead and to be honest I
think I've gotten used to the fact but I
surely would like to know what actually
happened I'll see what I can do did I
see what I can do I've I've explored a
lot what is what is in this role goodbye
apparently a sign on this case is break
in case of attic break it attic opening
stick I remember there being an attic I
definitely remember that miss gunns
vanity is elegant but not ostentatious
look in the mirror you take a long hard
look at yourself in the mirror and think
about the things you've done a lot of
those things were pretty cool yes they
were yes they were alright so there was
an attic somewhere maybe over here in
the billiards area I think that was like
an opening over here yeah yeah yeah here
okay blink easy peasy
oh hi okay this dresser is now dressed
as a ghost all right hello hey a mom
floor thumper dink but since I'm not the
guy who's apparently hiding out in Miss
Gunn's attic I feel like you ought to be
the one answering that question Who am I
well that's just frickin typical I'm
Chet bullet damn it how am I supposed to
have heard of that name before
yes you damn well shoulda miss gunns
invention would have been nothing
without mine wait let me let me guess
you invented the bullet proof
I thought you for sure you were gonna
say belt buckle again oh shoot now I
want to change my kiss you're damn right
I invented the bullet but I was her
assistant so I did I get any credit
he'll know I'll feel like maybe I'll
feel like dog sounds like you've got an
axe to grind not for much longer
yeah geez yeah it looks like we found
the bad guy
okay check go ahead and tell us the
details of your hole in the fairies plan
I don't care much for your tone why
should I tell you anything well if you
don't want to take credit for whatever
genius plan is I'm fine to let you
languish in obscurity huh well it's too
late for you to stop me anyway so I
suppose it wouldn't hurt to tell you
certainly not as much as not telling me
would when mrs. Gunn dies control the
company and Patton passes this to me
I'm no murderer mind you I'd like to
keep my hands clean but I figured there
might be some other people who'd have a
bone to pick with her considering the
manner of her death you summoned all
these ghosts that's right all it took
with some basic seance equipment wired
up to the house's belfry for
amplification a snap for mechanical
geniuses like me but seance gear summons
Ghost related to the Summoner that's the
whole point of a medium a person who
knows how to direct the summoning on
someone else's behalf so you get to talk
to your own grandma and serve the
summoner's you don't seem like a medium
to me more like a small but that does
explain something I've been wondering
about oh it didn't make any sense for
all the ghosts here to be haunting mrs.
Gunn because some of them weren't killed
by guns but they were all killed by
bullets naturally I anticipated that
there'd be a couple of those that's why
I rigged this room with an anti ghost
field which I cleverly boosted so that
ghosts couldn't even sense me up here so
your plan was to summon a bunch of angry
ghosts who would initially be looking
for you but would haunt mrs. gun instead
when they couldn't find you
correct and once they've all haunted her
to death Gunn industries will be all
mine well I hate to be the bearer of bad
news of good news but mrs. Gunn is dead
on the bright side she's been dead for a
year so you pretty much wasted your time
what really get out of here with all
those ghosts spotting me
yeah the ghosts are gone too so you're
pretty much in the clear wonderful the
anti ghost field was pretty effective
but it was starting to make the back
part of my brain itch he flips a switch
on the electrical device and you
suddenly become aware to the absence of
an extremely low-frequency hum right on
the edge of the hearing there's
something else I want to ask you about
ask away what happened to mrs. Gunn's
family oh then well they've been out of
the picture for years I heard a rumor
Dan got killed by Desperados and buried
in a shallow grave out in the back side
of nowhere but of course I wouldn't
actually know anything about that
hey lucky for me since I couldn't have
in here'd the company with him around or
their daughters
you son of a relax the girls are fine
I'm not a monster I'm pretty sure you're
a monster
there's a weird little island Kingdom
somewhere on the other side of the ocean
apparently it's stuck in some kind of a
bizarre temporal field that keeps nearly
anyone from entering or leaving can't
even find the place if you don't know
how fortunately I know of a guy who
knows how so I gave the girls three free
tickets to sleepaway camp wasn't that
nice to me you're an absolute bastard
oh that hurt my feelings fortunately I'm
about to have a whole lot of money to
console myself with why you hold on hold
on
we should talk to mrs. Gunn first before
you tear this ass a new hole huh I
thought you said she was dead depending
on what she says you might be too Oh
interesting
Oh interesting Oh interesting
the plot thickens the plot thickens
hello some good news and some bad news
Chad bullet had your husband killed in
your daughter's kidnap so he'd be the
sole inheritor of your company when you
died he's also the reason all the ghosts
were here
that son of a I should have suspected
something when he suddenly started being
so ingratiating back then and when he
did rode off Desperados on his expense
account oh that's funny I dried him out
of my will but I suppose it's too late
that's rather Garlin what's the good
news he says your daughters are safe
they're just on a magical island
somewhere that nobody could get to
that's not exactly comforting but at
this point I'll take it plainly if he'd
wanted to kill them he did just done so
wait you spoke to him personally yeah I
didn't know you weren't already dead so
he's been hiding in your attic for the
last couple of days waiting for the
ghost to kill you what do you want me to
do with him huh I'll leave it up to you
I'm not in a state to make any reasoned
judgment in any case you've answered my
question and I can feel myself moving on
already thank you for all your help with
a sad wave mrs. Gunn fades from view
then almost as an afterthought the lock
on her desk drawer pops open inside you
find a check written out to Cunningham
ghosts annihilation services which Flo
snags worth are charged sharing and a
blueprint mrs. Gunn's blueprint this
blueprint represents what would have
been the crowning achievement of mrs.
Gunn's career if she hadn't died before
actually getting into the production
okay
good can I make the most ultimate gun to
make me even more overpowered than I
already a.m. that'd be nice
hey I'm back thanks for waiting well are
we finished here
got a business to run I'm not done with
you yet wait here
I guess I am done with him aren't I I
mean what should I do I don't even know
he is an [ __ ] huh wait hang on a
second I know what I did if there's a
gun to like the ultimate gun I'm gonna
go I think in the basement there's a gun
manufacturing thing I'm gonna go make
the gun and then shoot this guy in the
face with that gun because I ain't about
the whole forgiveness shtick at the
moment make mrs. guns opus Wow
you follow the directions and construct
your final gift to the world this is the
best gun mrs. gun never got the chance
to make you vow to commit so much
violence in her name well you are god
damn right about that and you know
frankly I am exceptionally happy about
that is a big gun that's a big gun and
you know what else it needs it needs a
silencer I've already got a silencer oh
wait do I already have one do i oh I do
Oh sign with my pistol okay there we go
no one's gonna hear me shoot him in the
face no one I'm gonna shoot this guy in
the face so hard I'm gonna blast his ass
out of existence with mrs. guns magnum
opus get ready it's gonna be tricky with
all the internal bleeding
oh wow holy [ __ ]
what are those gonna do for me you just
shoot everything not sure if this is a
good idea
oh wait impervious to attack wait so I
have to destroy all of the huh
interesting well it would be unfortunate
if I used a bunch of bullets on these
boxes of bullets okay here's how we're
gonna do this I'm gonna use my bullets
set these on fire boom
oh-oh-oh
kaboom oh I'm a shooting Annie your ass
off on a shooting Annie your ass so good
I'm a shooter ass is grass buddy your
ass is grass yeah oh you give up what do
you mean you give up [ __ ] falls to his
knees who decided to let him dangle for
a minute with you while you rifle
through his stuff oh my god it's both
made of a new kind of lead that's even
worse for you than normal lead oh wow
that's a lot of bullets what do I just
throw bullets is that what I do you beat
the hell out of Chet bullet then hog
time and drag him down to the visitors
center the employees assure you they'll
hand them over to the sheriff or
whatever jurisdiction this is good
well that's it you reckon you brought
some reckon in a gun man or not with the
best-possible reckon in mind you maybe
there's a better way to deal with Chet
what no what wait wait what well I
didn't know this was here are you
kidding me oh are you kidding are you
are you kidding me [ __ ] are you if I
alt f4 out of the game where's it gonna
load me back in is it gonna load me back
in before I did anything is it gonna
worry they're gonna put me know it's
saving ow it's sinking ow it's sinking
up or you know it's gonna do I'm gonna
be da Oh screw that so hard
screw that so hard that makes me feel so
bad it makes me feel so I went through
this deal see as carefully as I could
and then when I think I'm at the end
with presented with the oh my god I bet
what I bet it is what I bet it is and I
didn't even know this existed until
after I had fought Chet what I bet it is
is that there was some way
to use this this um dislike device to
ring the bells to like summon some
ghosts or something god that makes me
feel so bad I was having such a good
time with this DLC I feel so bad that
makes me feel like [ __ ] that makes me
feel like a big pile of garbage
God [ __ ] deaf I was having such a
good oh man that really sucks
I guess that's the end but you know if
you just take this as a warning I guess
that you know if when if you're playing
this DLC there's another ending that you
can get if you don't fight the bad guy
that seems like you're supposed to fight
them so I guess I'll end it here can I
get some pity likes some pity subs some
pity bell rings just to make me feel
better I feel real bad real bad anyway
maybe someday I'll play through it again
I was having fun I mean this DLC is good
it is good I'm not saying like it heals
he's not good but man I feel feel like
[ __ ] now anyway sorry to end this on a
somber note but that is the end of
record and a gun manner this is great
DLC I had a lot of fun with it
I really did this had a lot of good
laughs had a lot of good jokes it didn't
repeat a lot of the old jokes it made a
lot of new funny stuff and it was
interesting to try to solve all these
mysteries of these ghosts with that said
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to see the rest of west of
loathing the link is in the description
below the whole playlist is there it is
a great game it really is if you haven't
played this for yourself you really got
it it's just so much fun there's so much
to do and this it's so in-depth and
there's a lot of choices that you got to
make that you got to be careful with
because if you make the wrong choice
sometimes then you know it will come
back to bite you in the ass but that I
guess that's just the nature of the game
so thank you everybody so much for
watching now as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]